Sadie I'm coming your way first because
I was reading a quote that Brendan had
given that said like he was so wowed by
how you were able to bring her internal
world to life like right before his eyes
the second you stepped in the door so it
was making me wonder is there any like
seemingly small detail that we don't
necessarily see on screen or hear about
via dialogue that was important to you
to flesh out that world that we can feel
when we watch the film
um
I mean I think with Ellie she she just
has a superpower with like observing
people and I feel like the wheels are
just constantly turning and for me
I think that was probably it just like
constantly reading every single facial
expression that Brendan makes
um
I guess I would say that you feel it
while you're watching your performance I
always had my eye on you because I
needed to know how you were assessing
everything that was happening around you
hung for you I caught I caught a quote
that you had said about Darren that he
has a way of being so technically
brilliant it can make you feel it can
make you think he's not feeling the
emotions but then you realize he is and
that was making me wonder when did you
process that and is it scary when you
think your director isn't feeling the
emotion initially before you realize
that he is I think was because we had a
three-week rehearsal period before we
started filming and I went to into that
rehearsal period thinking that it would
be
um
you know just a time for the actors to
just talk about their characters for a
bit but we hit the ground running for
that rehearsal it we started blocking
things almost immediately so that was a
little bit took some adjustment uh it
felt restrictive at first but then
within that we were able to play it was
just like um finding out the the
parameters of your sandbox and then
getting to like really go buck wild
within that even though it's a very tiny
tiny little sandbox it seems like a
really unique sandbox to get to play in
and like a really unique way of actually
shooting a movie too so is there any
part of the process that was unique to
making the whale that you both wish you
could experience on another set going
forward even if it's not you know a play
adaptation in a single location that
calls for that kind of shooting style
and for me it was that rehearsal process
and not just like blocking everything
out but also Darren kind of encouraged
us to just like sit and watch all the
other scenes that were being rehearsed
and I know I think that was
just a great way to like Focus us all
and bought and just a great bonding
experience
um so yeah I mean I would I would say
just the way that the rehearsal process
was approached I want to do that on
everything now yeah it's so important
for you to know what's going on with the
other characters even if you're not
necessarily in the scene with them
because then everybody knows what movie
that they're making we're all making the
same movie and you know coming out of
covid the lockdown and getting to work
on the whale
um
as the very first project just felt like
a miracle you know it was
so ambitious in terms of what they were
trying to do but the characters
themselves were just so rich and it's
based off of a play and they decided to
keep it that intimate instead of you
know adding 20 Superfluous characters
because we can it's a movie uh it just
felt it just felt really incredible I
have so many follow-up questions about
this rehearsal process and the idea of
being able to watch other people do
their scenes even when you're not in
them uh at first let's go with is there
anything while observing you saw another
the whale cast member do that made you
say like my God that was impressive I
want to take that technique put in my
back pocket and try it myself one day oh
yeah there was one for you where Darren
and I just shared a look because we were
just like our Jaws just dropped for this
one scene where you're yelling at
Brendan and that was on set that wasn't
in the rehearsal process and I was
sitting on an Apple box like off camera
and I was just like my God just a
Powerhouse so like that that was like a
key memory for me anything come to mind
uh well I remember just even before
getting to work with uh Sadie I had met
with the costume designer Danny and um
he was talking about Sadie and saying he
said something that I will remember her
her Talent is so accessible to her and I
was like that is a perfect way of
putting it once I saw her I was like
she's incredible she's amazing that
makes me so happy what a beautiful
description too I'll add a second part
to that that is more personal to you
because I could talk about the value of
a good scene partner all day long and
that seems vital to making a film like
this so was there ever a Time on set
when a scene partner gave you something
special that you really appreciated and
maybe helped you access something in
your own character that you wouldn't
have been able to without them I think
Brendan is amazing and I I had to do
process Aesthetics a little bit for
another movie but not to the extent that
Brendan had to for this film and I tell
you no actor wakes up wanting to wear
over 100 pounds of Prosthetics it's it's
it's a very difficult uh challenge to
act through all of that and
um the getting to watch Brendan
be so gracious while all these people
are buzzing around him adjusting
different things for him to be able to
compartmentalize all of that and give
the performance that he gave I will take
inspiration from that on every every
project that I do moving forward because
he could have easily been very cranky
and he wasn't he was just an absolute
angel I bet you say anything comes to
mind with a scene partner who brought
something out of your character I mean I
think I would say the same thing but
also for you you had like an infant at
home and yet you were choosing to just
work on not just any project but
something so like
training like this
so that was really inspiring I think for
me I was like oh yeah like yes I can
show up and know my lines and be as
prepared as possible because everyone
around us was it was just we all
understood how special this was and
we're all so eager to make it and
you know
push past the challenges that came with
it this this really is like a special
kind of performance showcase because
I've seen you both deliver big so many
times at this point but given the
special nature of this production and
how challenging the material is looking
back when you're sitting there watching
the final film is there any particular
scene of your own that makes you go like
like my God I'm so proud of myself that
I pulled that off and if I can do that I
can do anything going forward
um I think
um a little bit different I think it was
more um there was one scene that I
didn't think Darren would use the take
that he did and I was so happy
um that he kept it in the movie because
we had a little bit of a conversation
afterwards where he was like I don't I
don't think that's the road we want to
go down and I don't know what happened
but he kept it in the movie I need to
know I know now I'm really curious can
you give us a hint uh it's it's the one
when
um Charlie uh scares me okay okay okay
um
yeah I mean
I think there'd be some certain scenes
where you would just
I'm thinking of one in particular that I
won't say but like where I just kind of
left being like man like I should I
should have tried it this way or did you
just kind of like get in your head about
it
um but I think like watching the
finished product
it's just all like everything just
clicked and I don't think I've ever felt
as proud of something as I have for this
project so just in general
um but yeah very very happy with the
outcome for sure you should be this is
really something else and you two are
just crushing it this year my God thank
you for your time congratulations on the
whale thank you